hallo liebe leute und herzlich
willkommen zurück bei kali antwortet ich
beantworte wieder eure fragen zur
deutschen sprache und kultur
ja ich hätte euch versprochen dass diese
woche klaus dabei ist und eure fragen
mit beantwortet aber leider ist klaus
doch nicht hier denn er konnte nicht
klaus lässt sich allerdings
entschuldigen er wäre sehr gern dabei
gewesen aber er konnte tatsächlich heute
nicht deswegen wendet euch liebe grüße
und hofft dass er demnächst wieder dabei
sein kann
wir fangen an mit frage 1 und die kommt
heute von andy lorenz an die schreibt
was ist eigentlich der unterschied
zwischen möchten und wollen in welchem
fall muss man möchten benutzen und in
welchem fall wollen
im vergleich zu meiner muttersprache
haben die fast die gleiche bedeutung
ja beide worte möchten und wollen haben
auch die gleiche bedeutung allerdings
haben sie eine unterschiedliche stärke
wenn ich etwas will ist das sehr stark
wenn ich etwas möchte dann ist das
weniger stark das heißt man muss im
gespräch abwägen was von beidem man
benutzt wenn ich sage ich will einen
kaffee dann ist das quasi alternativlos
ich will jetzt den kaffee wenn ich
allerdings sollte ich möchte den kaffee
dann ist das sehr viel höflicher und
beim möchten kann man auch sagen wir mal
man hat noch alternativen wollen es eher
alternativ los ich will das und es gibt
keine kompromisse also wenn ich etwas
möchte von jemand anderem
da sage ich meistens ich möchte dass ich
hätte gerne einen kaffee
ich möchte gerne mit ihr sprechen wenn
ich sage ich will mit dir sprechen dann
klingt das so ein bisschen ja schon ein
bisschen zu stark
schon ein bisschen unhöflich die nächste
frage ist super spannend und sie kommt
von nucor abkam
lyko repka schreibt was ist ein
deutscher
was ist eine deutsche was kann man über
die deutsche identität sagen diese frage
super spannend und ich kann die mit
sicherheit nicht heute beantworten
wahrscheinlich kann man diese überhaupt
nicht beantworten aber ich kann es mal
versuchen
wenn man darüber redet wer in
deutschland eine deutsche ist kann man
das natürlich einmal rein rechtlich
sehen das deutsche
staatsbürgerschaftsgesetz also das
regelt wer hat eine deutsche
staatsbürgerschaft und werden
nicht sieht das sehr ethnisch kann man
sagen im vergleich zu anderen rechten
den usa zum beispiel gilt werden den usa
geboren ist ist ein amerikaner
in deutschland gilt das nicht unbedingt
in deutschland gilt quasi wer von einem
deutschen abstammt das heißt ein kind
eines deutschen ist auch ein deutscher
das heißt konkret wenn ich mit meinen
eltern meine eltern sind deutsch und ich
werde in den usa geboren bin ich
automatisch deutsche
wenn allerdings zwei amerikaner in
deutschland ein kind kriegen ist dieses
kind nicht automatisch auch ein
deutscher staatsangehöriger diese seite
erscheint einem natürlich erstmal sehr
stark
denn wenn man nur danach geht wer von
wem abstand ist es natürlich auch ein
bisschen schwierig gerade wenn viele
menschen nach deutschland einwandern
deshalb gibt es die möglichkeit für
menschen die schon sehr lange in
deutschland leben
genau genommen sind es acht jahre unter
bestimmten bedingungen die deutsche
staatsbürgerschaft zu erwerben ich
stelle euch mal unten ein paar links
rein da könnt ihr sehen wie man das
machen kann wie das abläuft ist es sehr
interessant ich kenne auch leute dir das
schon gemacht haben das heißt wenn ihr
zum beispiel aus brasilien kommt oder
aus den usa und ihr lebt seit acht
jahren permanent in deutschland könnt
ihr deutsche staatsbürger werden
eine viel schwierigere frage ist
natürlich die frage nach der deutschen
identität
was ist eigentlich die identität eines
deutschen tatsächlich kann man das
schwer sagen denn man kann jetzt nicht
sagen es gibt den typischen deutschen
oder die typische deutsche identität und
identität ist auch immer etwas wo man
sehr viel streitet in deutschland und
man streitet natürlich nicht nur in
deutschland sondern in vielen anderen
ländern
es gibt zum beispiel immer wieder die
debatte natürlich fragt ein mann
besonders stellt man sich die
identitätsfrage wenn man selber ins
ausland geht oder wenn viele ausländer
nach deutschland kommen
früher zum beispiel habe ich selber
immer gedacht ja ich mag typisch deutsch
sei nicht ich mag gar nicht was typisch
deutsch ist und ich selber bin schon gar
nicht typisch deutsch das hab ich
gedacht als ich also anfang 20 war
und umso mehr ich dann selber ins
ausland
umso mehr ich andere kulturen kennen
gelernt habe umso mehr habe ich auch
gelernt fast typisch deutsches und ich
mußte feststellen daß ich typisch
deutsch bin auch wenn ich das eigentlich
nie wollte
ja wenn ihr mich fragt was ist
eigentlich typisch deutsch da gehört
natürlich unheimlich viel dazu was
gehört zu einer kultur dazu
dazu gehört zum beispiel zeitverständnis
familien zusammenleben wie ist die
arbeit in einem land organisiert dazu
gehört natürlich so was wie sprache wie
es der staat organisiert hieß politik
organisiert wie empfindet man sich
innerhalb einer familie ganz viele
verschiedene sachen
ich nehme einfach mal drei beispiele für
mich erstes beispiel kommunikation
deutsche sind sehr direkt da haben wir
ja auch schon mal drüber diskutiert als
wir zum beispiel die episode haben was
denken deutsche über die usa
deutsche sind sehr direkt sehr ehrlich
manchmal und das kann auch oft hart sein
wenn es zum beispiel um negative meinung
geht
zweiter punkt zum beispiel ist das
zeitverständnis deutsche haben so ein
sehr strenges zeitverständnis das heißt
wenn man in deutschland sagt man trifft
sich um 3 uhr dann sind die meisten
deutschen traum vom vorreiter und das
ist wirklich so wenn man zu spät kommen
das gibt es natürlich auch
dann kommt man wirklich maximal zehn
minuten 15 zu spät
alles was darüber ist gilt in
deutschland als unhöflich und das muss
man natürlich wissen wenn man aus einem
land kommt wo ist dieses verständnis
nicht gibt einfach weil es nicht
relevant ist und weil es ja weil meine
andere kultur hat in deutschland kann
leute tatsächlich sauer sein wenn man so
spät kommt und ich selber aber dass auch
gemerkt dass ich ich habe immer gedacht
das ist mir egal wenn ich in anderen
ländern bin ist es mir auch egal ich
finde es sogar entspannend wenn leute
nicht so streng sind aber tatsächlich
hier selber wenn ich bei mir im büro bin
und leute sagen sie kommen um 1 und dann
kommen sie irgendwie um halb vier dann
empfinde ich das selber mittlerweile
auch als unhöflich und noch ein drittes
beispiel was ich öfter mit freunden
diskutieren ist immer dieser unterschied
zwischen individualismus und
kollektivismus das heißt was stelle ich
in den vordergrund mich als individuum
oder die gemeinschaft als kollektiv
und es gibt vor nachteile was ich zum
beispiel sehr spannend finde ist dass es
in vielen gesellschaften die einstellung
gibt es die familie wichtiger ist als
alles andere das heißt wenn man zum
beispiel einer familie hatten job und
jemand anders hat keinen dann teilt man
mit man miteinander man teilt sich das
haus man passt schon zum beispiel auf
die kinder auf oder wenn die eltern
arbeiten dann können die kinder auch bei
dem onkel oder bei der tante von in
deutschland gibt es so was nicht das
heißt in deutschland ist man viel mehr
auf die individuelle freiheit aus man
möchte immer man steht immer selbst im
mittelpunkt und das hat natürlich vor
und nachteile einerseits treffe ich
meine entscheidung für mich selbst und
ich lasse mir auch nicht von meinen
eltern oder von meinen großeltern oder
tanten und onkels sagen was ich tun oder
machen soll und das heißt für uns ist
freiheit sehr sehr wichtig und das ist
auch gut
andererseits denke ich auch manchmal
dass es schade ist wenn man in
deutschland sieht das ist zum beispiel
geschwister gibt die sich zerstreiten
und nie wieder miteinander reden das ist
in deutschland gar nicht so untypisch
oder wenn man sieht dass sich menschen
über erbschaften streiten oder das alte
menschen nicht mehr in der familie
wohnen sondern in einem heim wohnen
solche sachen habe ich das gefühl ganz
oft in anderen ländern sind die anders
geregelt und natürlich muss man da mehr
kompromisse eingehen aber es ist
manchmal auch sehr schön
nächste frage kommt von sohn schenken er
fragt sind die münsteraner freundlich
denn in den videos scheinen sie immer so
freundlich
die antwort ist ja und nein also das
kann man gar nicht sagen weil schon sind
sie freundlich wir hatten jetzt auch
wieder das gefühl zum beispiel im
vergleich zu berlin
der original berliner ist generell ein
bisschen mehr unfreundlicher als der
münsteraner münsteraner können aber auch
unfreundlich sein was ihr im video seht
sind ja auch nur die netten menschen ihr
müsst wissen wir gehen manchmal
stundenlang über die straße und 50
prozent der leute manchmal auch mehr
sagen uns wir wollen nicht mit euch
reden
das heißt das was ihr seht sind die nets
sind die leute die wir schon ausgewählt
haben weil sie nett aussehen oder sie
freundlich aussehen und von denen sind
das auch noch die leute die geantwortet
haben und von denen sie
das auch noch die besten antworten von
den antworten das heißt ihr seht
eigentlich nur die nettesten deutschen
um mal fair zu sein
die letzte frage für heute kommt von
russkaja 009 ruska schreibt hallo ich
mag eure episoden liebe kari dankeschön
ich würde gerne wissen ob es
interessante deutsche aberglauben gibt
ja das ist auch interessant weil ich
hätte jetzt als erstes mal gedacht nein
gibt es nicht also natürlich gibt es
immer so aber glauben aber ich würde
sagen generell gibt es nicht so viele
leute die an bestimmte sachen glauben
aber ich habe das mal gegoogelt und
natürlich gibt es verschiedene er über
glauben die ich auch kenne und ich werde
euch mal ein paar vorlesen von denen die
ich ein bisschen interessant und
vielleicht auch witzig finde so dame
doch schon einen tollen aberglaube
gefunden manche menschen glauben das ist
glück bringt wenn ein vogel bei einem
menschen auf die schulter oder den kopf
takt nächste aberglaube wenn du niest
oder schluckauf hast dann denkt gerade
jemand an dich als schweine gelten als
glücksbringer in deutschland das ist
interessant tatsächlich gibt es zu
bestimmten festen zum beispiel silvester
das neue jahr
da gibt es immer man sich so kleine
schweine und schornsteinfeger als so
kleine zum beispiel aus marzipan oder
anderen süßigkeiten zum essen oder auch
als figuren die man irgendwo drauf klebt
angeblich bringt das glück schweine
schornsteinfeger kleeblätter und
hufeisen oder marienkäfer bringen glück
einen zu finden und auf der hand zu
haben bringt noch mehr glück dann
erinnere ich mich noch als kinder haben
wir immer marienkäfer gesammelt also man
darf man niemals töten oder wegschauen
das bringt unglück mann soll in
deutschland nicht vom teufel sprechen
denn wenn man vor ihm spricht dann kommt
er
wer gestolpert ist sollte ein stück
zurückgehen um die stelle erneut
überschreiten um unglück abzuwenden
oder es ist eine dies kommt tatsächlich
mal eine die auch praktiziert wird beim
game
nimmt man die hand vor den mund wenn man
geld macht man so was heute eine
selbstverständliche geste guten
benehmens ist hat im kern einen
arabische bedeutung nämlich die zu
verhindert die verhindert dass böse
geister in mücken gestalt in den mund
gelangen können habe ich noch nie gehört
heute macht man das aus höflichkeit hier
noch ein aberglaube die liste ist
unendlich lang auf dem polterabend
porzellan zerdeppern soll böse dämonen
in die flucht schlagen und dadurch dem
brautpaar eine glückliche ehe bescheren
das hat man tatsächlich immer noch den
polterabend wo man sachen kaputt wirft
tassen teller alles auf dem boden also
im prinzip gibt es noch ganz viele
aberglauben die sich immer darauf
beschränken um ein glück oder umgekehrt
sehr verbreitet ist auch schwarze katzen
bringen unglück oder unter leitern
hergehen bringen unglück wurde zum
beispiel freitag der dreizehnte ist
traditionell ein unglückstag
generell muss man aber sagen von den
meisten aber glauben die hier bei
wikipedia stehen von denen habe ich noch
nie gehört das heißt sie sind würde ich
behaupten in deutschland nicht so
verbreitet viele kommen noch aus der
alten zeit aus dem mittelalter noch aus
der frühen neuzeit und heute kennt man
sie teilweise noch aber ich glaube so
richtig viel arbeit glauben gibt es in
deutscher nicht mehr
ja das war's um für diese woche danke
fürs zuschauen danke für eure
unterstützung bei petri an ich hoffe
dass wir demnächst doch mal noch mal
eine episode mit klaus machen
ich freue mich dass ihr zu gesehen habt
und freue mich auf eure neuen kommentare
und bis zum nächsten mal